ce qui est honteux c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de faire monsieur là ça
vous n'avez pas à vous lever et à hurler
dans l'assemblée vous connaissez le
règlement mais s'est pas uni monsieur la
salle vous n'avez plus de droit de
parole sur mfm
non mais vous faites partie des non
inscrits il n'y a plus de temps de
parole
vous n'êtes pas un sou député vous
connaissez le règlement vous n'êtes pas
vous monsieur la salle rappel au
règlement madame ménard
[Musique]
ce qui est honteux c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de faire monsieur là ça
vous n'avez pas à vous lever et à hurler
dans l'assemblée vous connaissez le
règlement mais c'est pas une île sais
pas monsieur monsieur la salle s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît calmez vous calmez
vous je vous expliquais le règlement si
vous étiez là au tout début de la séance
vous auriez entendu que les non-inscrits
n'ont plus de droit de parole et vous
faites partie des non-inscrits
je vous remercie de respecter le
règlement vous n'êtes pas monsieur s'il
vous plaît ce soit vous sortez monsieur
la salle monsieur la salle ça y est vous
avez terminé je vous remercie en revoit
me remerciez pas
madame ménard
alex lui madame s merci